foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
for evening service at marguerges church
mingle with the Tranquility of mangesh
this Village is home to More Than 3 000
Kurds in the northern province of Duke
for centuries Chaldean Catholics and
Muslims have lived here in harmony
we share our Muslim neighbors religious
festivals as well as Joys and Sorrows a
village has always been distinguished by
its tolerance without discrimination
this is a blessing from God
sectarian loyalties have fueled unrest
in some areas of Iraq
since the 2003 U.S led Invasion the
people of mangisk say they're proud of
their coexistence and acceptance of each
other
they say that Harmony between Christians
and Muslims here has created an
unbreakable social bond that has
resulted in economic and political gains
for everyone in the village
it's not only social tradition that
ensures peace here but also modern
politics in the semi-autonomous Kurdish
region
consensus between Muslims and Christians
over supporting one political party has
returned to the village with improving
infrastructure and services
but the mayor of mangish Hannah Gul
wishes worried that this might be
disrupted by military operations nearby
as fighters from the Kurdistan Workers
Party or pkk Patrol the area
in some cases their positions are
targeted by Turkish Air Raids that
terrifies our people they should leave
our lands and Tackle their conflict with
takier inside Turkish borders
turkey as well as the US and the EU call
the pkk a terror organization
the group is accused of killing Assyrian
civilians from mangesh in 1997 an
accusation the pkk denies
but as turkia continues military
operations along its border with Iraq
the people of mangish Hope The Village
will stand as a safe haven
and symbol of peaceful coexistence in
the region
foreign